die kanzlerin hat sich gestern eher
durchwachsen geäußert sie hat einerseits
gelobt wie toll er seinen job macht er
hat sie hat gelobt wie früh er sich um
die den aufbau von weiteren
produktionskapazitäten für impfstoff
gekümmert habe andererseits hat sie dann
aber auch eingeräumt dass im ersten und
zweiten quartal wollen nicht genügend
impfstoff zur verfügung steht um dem
dritten das dann besser werden wird das
dritte quartal geht bekanntlich bis ende
september
was ist da eigentlich nun dran ist das 1
1 eine art jonglage mit dem image des
ministers oder wie darf man das
verstehen
das hat man genauso falsch zu verstehen
wie die kanzlerin sich neulich ja auch
wir haben ja beide beobachtet geäußert
hat nach dem gipfel mit dem
ministerpräsidenten da hat sie sich
hinter jens spahn gestellt aber nicht
davor und jetzt steht sie hinter ihm und
hat ihm einfach eigentlich ganz klein
mit dem was du da zitiert hast auch ins
knie getreten fand von hinten in die
kniekehle reihen das ein bisschen
zusammen geld sagt würde ich mal sagen
denn wenn sie in einerseits lobt dass er
frühzeitig angefangen hat auf der
anderen seite arbeit sagt dass wir vom
dritten quartal eigentlich nicht
genügend impfstoff haben werden dann
sagt sie er hat sich angestrengt aber
das klassenziel nicht ganz erreicht weil
das hat nicht ausgereicht was entspannen
da offensichtlich gemacht hat jetzt muss
man andererseits aber auch sagen dass
ich entspannen natürlich auch in der
gefangenschaft der kanzlerin politik ist
und wenn die kanzlerin hat bestimmt wir
machen das alles über die eu und jetzt
du verhandelt nicht nebenbei dann ist da
in einer gewissen zwangsjacke er kann ja
jetzt nicht auf möglich werden
und auf der anderen seite zeigt jetzt
die kanzlerin regelmäßig mit kleinen
nadelstichen ganz ganz ganz kleinen
freunden freundlich lächelnd wo seine
grenzen sind
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren